sí
muy bien hasta el momento has hecho un
solo objeto de forma el cual contiene
información para dibujar un círculo pero
necesitamos más formas para construir
nuestro muñeco de nieve y queremos
guardar todas esas formas dentro de una
estructura de datos que representen
nuestro modelo de muñeco de nieve una
manera que podemos hacer esto es con un
arreglo donde cada posición dentro del
arreglo contiene un objeto de forma
para hacer esto en el siguiente
ejercicio definidas un arreglo llamado
arreglo de formas piensa en el arreglo
de formas como nuestro modelo completo
tiene todo lo que la computadora
necesita para dibujar todas las piezas
del modelo pero qué hacemos con el
sombrero para nik no podemos dibujar eso
con círculos eso sería una locura
el cortometraje knick knack se realizó
con formas geométricas sencillas una
manera fácil de dibujar una nueva forma
es definir una serie de puntos llamados
vértices por ejemplo el sombrero
necesitaría ocho vértices como éste cada
uno de estos puntos está representado
por un par de coordenadas
luego la lista completa de estos
vértices puede guardarse en un arreglo
más grande así que tendremos un arreglo
de arreglos para guardar cualquier forma
que queramos y permitiremos que otra
parte del programa conecte esos puntos
por nosotros en primer lugar tenemos dos
ejercicios para ti en el primer
ejercicio crearás un arreglo de formas
para guardar cada uno de estos objetos
de forma esto te permitirá agregar tu
cabeza y tu cuerpo
después de eso tendrás la oportunidad de
crear cualquier forma
empezando por el clásico sombrero negro
que te diviertas adelante